suzak is using the 150 500 fo focus on
me as we see in iguana there hey you
recording look at this critter let's go
closer zack oh hello iguana hello
do not run away don't go ah you left
did you get him zacky
did you get up it's raining really heavy
no wonder he wants to go underneath the
trees i should do the same i'm not built
for this my hair definitely is not
hey everybody what is going on yes i'm
on a brand new channel but i'm still
here to talk about cameras in my hands
today is the all new tamron 150 to 505
to 6.7 on the sony alpha one what is
this combo like to use we're going to
talk all about that but before we get
into that i do want to answer some of
those questions you might be having yes
i did move over from tech 360 to geek
culture yes i'll be talking about other
things besides cameras but i'm still
going to focus on cameras and
videography and all that great stuff
because this is my passion like yours as
well and i'm super excited about being
here with the new team uh zach are we
going to call this camera culture what
are we going to call this exactly click
culture maybe click culture maybe we
don't know yet we'll find out but just
uh bear with us as we grow through this
and uh build this journey together so
with that guys let's talk about the
all-new tamron okay so we're not paid or
sponsored for this review my thoughts
and my thoughts only we're going to talk
about the lens i'll also talk about the
performance on the alpha one but that
will be coming out throughout this
review but let's focus on the lens first
now tamron has been known to make some
fantastic very attractive price uh sony
e-mount lenses over the past couple
years we're actually using the 2875 on
the sony a7 3 to record this currently
and this super zoom lens from tamron i
think is going to attract a lot of
people case in point the price is around
2 000 singapore dollars plus some free
gifts uh if you pre-order which is very
attractive for a 150 to 500 super zoom
lens now it is an f5 to 6.7 it's a
variable aperture lens but for a 150 to
500 it's not super heavy it's not that
light it's right in the middle which i
guess you could say is just right but
let's talk about some of the features on
this lens you have a lock switch so of
course this locks it from extending on
its own inside your bag then you also
have a lock mode on the focus ring here
so whatever focal range i'm at i can
actually lock it
and i'm going to stay there which is a
nice addition to have it is a telescopic
zoom lens i prefer an internal zoom but
again that does make a lens a lot
heavier and it does cost a little bit
more so
this lens is what it is but it still
performs beautifully we'll talk about
the image quality later on let's talk
about the various different modes and
switches you have on this you have three
different vc modes you have vc mode one
two and three this is tamron's image
stabilization
on the lens you have vc on and off af
and mf and of course you have full three
meters and 15 meters for your focal
range in terms of how it auto focuses
you are pretty much covered in that
regard what most other super zoom lenses
have this has it inside a tripod ring
here as well you can turn it around or
you can actually take it off which is a
nice addition to have the some of the
sony lenses actually have this mount
attached to the bottom of the lens
directly this has that ring so teach
their own i actually like this option
because it does give you that
you know variation however you want to
set it up and then you have the lens
hood which is a plastic lens hood but it
is pretty durable with rubber tip at the
bottom of it so do knock it into
something it will protect it and of
course you're not going to get those
scratches on the end of your hood or
they won't show as badly it's a welcome
addition it's a pretty robust plastic
it's not too big of a lens hood which is
nice so that's pretty much the lens in a
nutshell let's talk about what's inside
a bad place to put a bag
all right
there is ants all over the bag right
outdoors sweating all that fun stuff
so let's talk about what's inside of
this lens we have 25 elements 16 groups
we can of course have an 82 millimeter
on the filter diameter on this the
weight comes in and as i said 1.9 kg 4.2
pounds uh of course you have close
focusing on this up to 60 cm so that
gives you sort of that pseudo macro
capabilities that we're used to seeing
on other tamron e-mount lenses you're
also going to find it in this 150-500
now obviously this is a full-frame lens
but if you want to use it in aps-c mode
especially on the alpha 1 you are going
to extend the range of this lens quite
significantly around 700 plus
millimeters thereabouts at your longest
focal range so this is a very uh
competent lens in that regard and it has
very fast autofocusing motors in it so i
can tell you we'll talk about
performance in just a bit but just right
here just a little bit of a cliff notes
version it autofocus is about the same
speed as a native sony g master or g
lens on the alpha one with that
let's talk about what it's like to use
let's clear one elephant in the room out
right away you're not going to get 30
frames per second with the alpha one
with this 150-500 now this is something
that we were told about from sony
initially with this camera that third
party lenses you're not going to get
that optimal performance out of the
camera system and that is true with this
150 to 500
um in terms of what my frame count is
it's around
15 to 20 frames there abouts per second
that's a rough estimate i was trying to
time it but it's around there they're
about it's not set it with release mode
on the shutter button of course afc at h
plus so i have it set optimally and but
that is
unfortunately what it is but it's not a
deal breaker because to be honest with
you as i mentioned previously when i did
talk about the alpha one is that the 30
frames per second only lasts about five
seconds before the buffering kicks in on
this camera so pretty much 20 frames per
second there bounce is where you're
going that's your sweet spot with this
camera system even though it can do 30
you're not always going to want to use
30 because it's a lot of images to clear
and especially in your post editing
process it's a lot of images to delete
as well because with 30 frames it's
every little bit my note of a second now
of course if you're birding or into
wildlife those images might count a
little bit more but for a lot of the
average photographers out there you
won't miss a thing with this system
but in terms of autofocus
as i mentioned earlier there is no
difference using this lens versus
a native g master or g lens from sony i
took this at the zoo i shot a variety of
different images with it it is fast it
is precise eye tracking works great on
animals um you know sony's animal eye
tracking of course is getting better and
better um in terms of human eye tracking
it's fantastic
no issues at all in terms of
autofocusing now in terms of the vc
modes on this now sony's not known to
have the best image stabilization in
their camera systems and even with this
vc mode on this system
super stable again it's okay it
definitely does help but when you are at
500 millimeters or if you're an aps-c
motion around 700 plus millimeters you
are going to see a little bit of camera
shake so of course at those ranges a lot
of people will be using a monopod or a
tripod especially if they're going to be
doing birding or wildlife so it won't be
much of an issue for you but if you're
going to go handheld with this do take
note that you are going to see a little
bit of camera shake and lens shake with
this setup besides that though the
images are very sharp
tamron's always been known to have some
very pleasing images coming out of the
lens and the same with this one great
bokeh great fall off i have no issues at
all with the quality of image coming
from this lens whatsoever images have a
nice little saturation to them a nice
little punch to them uh the colors look
fantastic especially with the alpha one
if you want to shoot in a semitone or
just shoot in just no profile at all
you're gonna be very happy with the
performance color wise out of this lens
okay so in terms of when the aperture
changes at 150 we are at f5
then if we move to about 250
goes to 5.6
at 400 a little over 400 we're at 6.3
and at
6.7
so pretty decent of course if we go to
apsc mode that will extend it even
further so and the close focusing on
this as you can tell i'm about um
three three and a half meters four
meters and i'm actually able to focus on
him at 500 millimeters on this lens
that's pretty impressive
so now we're testing video on the 150 to
500 on so uh zaki's sony a73 we're at
500 millimeters right now and of course
it's locked onto me all is great now why
would you use video for a lens like this
well if you're a private investigator if
you do want to do some video of birds in
flight or wildlife or a sporting event
this lens does come in handy in that
regard now i'm actually going to walk
closer to the lens it's okay guys come
on don't be shy it's okay
all good
this is gonna track me a little bit as
we're gonna see the eye tracking is
still really good just like a native
sony lens now the vc will be a little
bit hit miss of course this is a much
heavier lens so we're using a monopod in
this regard but as you can tell it is
sticking on me pretty well and zacky is
mastering the 150 to 500 and it's
starting to rain a little bit zacky to
be honest with you i mean lens is
weather resistant we're not worried
about that my hair is not
but we're not worried about my hair it's
more about the lens right
actually i'm worried about my hair it
won't look good on camera
but it is what it is
so my final thoughts on this lens as
it's starting to pour rain down on me
but
it's weather resistant so no issues at
all i really like this lens for what it
is um the price point around 2 000
singapore dollars around 1 300 us
dollars thereabouts it's a fantastic
performing lens at that price now again
it will not give you the optimal
performance like you're going to see on
a native sony g master lens or g lens at
30 frames per second on the alpha one
but it will get you around 15 to 20
frames per seconds which is more than
adequate and for most people out there
they've captured some beautiful images
even with that high burst mode on that
image quality is fantastic it's sharp
great a book on this very controlling
the operation and it's just a fantastic
performing lens i do wish vc was a
little bit better implemented it's a
little bit shake here and there and i do
wish this wasn't a 6.7 lens but ended up
to be a 5.6 lens at its maximum aperture
for or wide open aperture in that regard
but
for the price point i really can't
complain anyway those are my thoughts on
the lens let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below do you agree
with me is this the lens you're looking
to pick up i would love to hear from you
guys anyway thank you for joining me
here at geek culture stay safe take care
follow us on facebook subscribe to us on
youtube like this video helps out our
channel quite a bit with that guys take
care stay safe and i'm gonna get out of
the ring now bye
[Music]